[Music]
thank you
on Journey to the micro Cosmos we love
microbes we love to see them swim and
wander and live out their unique lives
but we've also had to make peace with
the fact that the micro Cosmos is not a
peaceful Utopia this is a world where
microbes are both residents and food
which means that occasionally we'll have
to spend our time together watching
organisms whose bodies are fractions
upon fractions upon fractions of a
millimeter in size turn into vicious
predators
so today in honor of both predator and
prey we're going to be revisiting some
of our favorite videos about eating in
the micro Cosmos grab a snack and join
our microbes as they snack and we'll
start by revisiting some of the clever
strategies that microbes use to gather
their prey
despite huge differences in morphology
and biological structures all living
organisms do the same three basic things
they get food digest it and excrete
waste materials living organisms require
energy to live some produce their own
food usually through photosynthesis we
call these autotrophs but many organisms
cannot make their own food we call these
heterotrophs and they eat
[Music]
among heterotrophic single-celled
eukaryotes food is taken into the cell
in various methods but once it's there
it's wrapped by a membrane and forms
something called a food vacuole then the
cell flushes digestive enzymes inside
the food vacuole to start the digestion
nutrients are taken into the cytoplasm
and the waste material left in the
vacuole then basically fuses with the
outer membrane of the cell and what's
left in the vacuole is discharged into
the environment in some cases like
inside this beautiful single-celled
nasila or NADA which feeds on
filamentous cyanobacteria content of the
food vacuole reacts with the digestive
enzymes and changes color that process
takes time because each vacuole formed
at a different time they are in
different stages of digestion which
gives this cell its colorful polka dots
but how do these heterotrophic organisms
get their food well in spite of a
remarkable amount of diversity a lot of
microorganisms use one of the same three
strategies for getting their food some
of this will be familiar to the macro
World some of it will not
one of the less familiar is filter
feeding which allows larger organisms to
consume suspended food particles or much
smaller organisms there are filter
feeders in the macro World Baleen whales
come to mind but while a whale must swim
through giant clouds of small organisms
in the microcosmos your food can come to
you
some filter feeders use hair-like
structures called cilia to create a
Vortex that brings other microorganisms
or food particles to the cell mouth
these cilia are specialized for this
task and their beating creates a current
that expediently and beautifully directs
every nearby thing into the waiting
mouth of the microorganism the Cilia are
often too small for us to see but you
can see their effects
take a look at these paramecia they're
consuming tiny tiny bacteria and you can
see resilia causing small organisms to
Tumble across them you can also see all
of their food vacuoles on the inside and
if you look very carefully you can see a
new food vacuole forming getting filled
up with those tiny bacterial cells
foreign
[Music]
T and most obvious filter feeders are
rotifers micro animals that use cilia to
create swirling vortices around their
mouth Parts you can see how successful
this feeding strategy is by its belly
full of algae cells every time its mouth
fills with more algae it contracts to
swallow the food
now observe these single-celled
organisms called stentors they are much
bigger than most other microorganisms
you can actually see them with the naked
eye and they also use filter feeding to
push all of their algal food into their
cell mouths
[Music]
our second feeding mechanism may be the
most familiar and the most exciting is
called raptorial feeding raptorial
feeders selectively capture prey and
punt other organisms in this video you
can see the leptus hunting it paralyzes
one organism with the touch of its
trunk-like proboscis and then it pulls
that organism into itself in a process
called phagocytosis
many of these microorganisms are armed
with something called toxics these are
little harpoon-like structures filled
with toxins and they're located on a
particular part of the cell which the
microorganism uses for hunting these
tiny harpoons are then fired when they
come in contact with prey organisms
which then become immobilized
this is bursaria It's a single-celled
organism with a huge mouth and things
have not gone well for the paramecium
that is now incited the paramecium dies
immediately because of the toxics on the
inside of the bursaria so at least it
was quick
foreign
now get ready for some truly gorgeous
footage of a micro animals day going
south first paradoleptus immobilizes the
rotifer with fired toxics and the animal
is swallowed by the single-celled
organism as it swims away
[Music]
it's frontonia which is a close relative
of paramecia but it lacks the
filter-feeding habits of its relatives
and feeds predaciously on large diatoms
and filamentous cyanobacteria such as
oscillatoria here though in this case it
turns out this frontonia bit off a
little more than he could chew
another raptorial feeding style is
called histophagy histophagus organisms
such as these single-celled collapse
attack injured but live animals or other
single-celled organisms sucking off
hunks of tissue rather than consuming
whole organisms when they attack an
animal they enter wounds and ingest
tissue often attacking in groups because
their chemical sensing abilities attract
many of them from a distance like
microscopic vultures when a number of
them Gather in one place it's hard to
avoid another macro World analog
piranhas devouring everything soft in no
time at all
there's a huge variety of raptorial
feeding this is just the beginning but
we wanted to show you one more before we
move on this is vampire Ella an amoeba
with a suitable name it specializes in
feeding on filamentous algae first it
bores a hole through the algal cell wall
and then slurps out the gooey nutritious
cytoplasm
[Music]
our final feeding mechanism for today at
least is diffusion feeding in which the
Predator just sits in the same place
relying on the prey to accidentally make
contact
this is a heliozoa it's a single-celled
amoeboid and because of its resemblance
to the sun due to the Rays coming out of
its cell it's sometimes called the Sun
animalcule the rays are called axipodia
These are sometimes used in Locomotion
and in this case for hunting prey
axapodia are cytoplasmic extensions
meaning they're a part of the cell
membrane even though they look like
they're sticking out of it each one has
a central supporting Rod of microtubules
that gives it this rigid structure the
axopodia are coated in organelles that
discharge toxins when touched which
impair or even paralyze heliozoa's prey
after the organism is captured those
microtubules are drawn back into the
cell thus retracting the axopodia and
allowing the cell to swallow The Unlucky
organism or prey is just engulfed by
extrusions from the cell called
pseudopodia
in this video a road of fur has been
captured by ahilia zoa and is slowly
getting eaten by it now this is
something that happens fairly frequently
but we did capture something unusual
here while it was stuck to heligozoa's
expodia this rotifer actually lays its
egg but neither egg nor the rotifer is
going to escape this
surprisingly heartbreaking
this is a sanctorian it's a ciliate just
like paramecium and stenter these
organisms have hair like cilia during
the early stage of their life but as
adults they develop bundles of tentacles
just like in heliozoa these tentacles
are supported by an internal cylinder of
microtubules
of the tentacles have extrusomes these
are special structures that attach to
and immobilize any other ciliates that
touch them tentacles eventually
penetrate the cell membrane of the prey
and then the contents of the prey is
sucked out through the tentacle in this
clip a sanctorian has caught four
individual vorticella with its tentacles
and is slowly sucking their cytoplasm it
looks a little like the forticella have
the sanctorian surrounded but in fact
they are powerless to escape it
it's a dangerous world out there the
complex chemicals created by organisms
to sustain their life necessarily are
useful to other organisms as building
blocks and as fuel and so predation
evolved
beautiful it's constant and it's brutal
[Music]
now that we've seen how the hunters of
the microcosmos get their food let's
experience the more challenging part of
the Predator prey Dynamic getting eaten
for the organisms in our next video
finding themselves in the belly of the
beast is just the start of a more
grueling process one that converts their
bodies into nutrients
foreign
[Music]
grades are famous for their capacity to
survive if you if you look them up you
will be inundated with long lists of the
many things that scientists have thrown
their way to see if the tardigrade Will
Survive we've made some lists like those
ourselves tardigrades on the moon
tardigrades in extreme heat you've heard
about them we've talked about them what
else is there well here's a surprising
fact you might not have known for a
certain species of tardigrades like the
one in the middle of your screen right
now you can tell the difference between
a male and a female by looking at their
toes that's right the toes these
tardigrades are called magnesium and the
males of these species have a pair of
claws on their feet that are shaped a
little bit differently from the rest of
the claws with only one hook on each
claw instead of the usual two but after
taking a closer peek at this
tardigrade's toes we can confirm that
she is a female tardigrade now that's a
fun fact for us as we watch this clip
but it does not actually do anything for
the poor rotifers that are surrounding
this tardigrade who are currently
stretching themselves in and out of
danger
around the tip of a tardigrade's mouth
are small bumps that we think act like
little sensors and when those bumps make
contact with a rotifer out pops the
tardigrades stylet a little needle that
pokes out from the tubular mouth opening
that style it pokes into the rotifer and
from there the tardigrade uses a
circular structure called a pharynx in
its head to create strong suction and
then the style it goes from functioning
as a needle to functioning as a portable
built-in straw that lets the tardigrade
suck out the inside of its prey
you can see some of that bodily fluid
leaving the rotifer as the tardigrade
stylet pumps away like a beating heart
and when she is done the rotifer remains
like an empty coffee cup
this method of eating Works quite well
for the tardigrade letting her eat
quickly from the prey that is directly
in front of her but not all organisms
come equipped with a weapon that lets
them turn rotifers into Capri Suns these
organisms have to turn to other methods
to extract nutrients from their food
this Marine ciliate is called
kentrophilum and it came to James our
master of microscopes in a large
container full of beach sand on a normal
day maybe we would talk more about its
funny almond shape that stretches as it
swims around but today is not a normal
day because this kendrophilum is about
to be overshadowed by a rotifer now
where is the rotifer you might ask it is
inside the kentrofilam of course we did
not catch the moment of its capture when
the toxic needles lining the kentrofilam
darted out and paralyzed the rotifer by
the time we arrived the rotifer had
already been ingested but it was not
dead yet
[Laughter]
[Music]
you can see it wiggling and wrestling at
the broad end of the kentru film causing
the ciliate's body to wrinkle and fold
in on itself but it is trapped inside of
a food vacuole now a compartment that
exists to break this rotifer down sure
the rotiver can try and fight against
the walls of the vacuole holding it
hostage but there's not much it can do
against the digestive enzymes pouring in
or the increasing acidity of its
surroundings a food vacuole is a hostile
place to be and for minutes its
destructive tools will go to work
in the end the rotifer will be left in
dissolved pieces to be absorbed by the
kentrophilum cytoplasm sustaining the
organism that was the site of its last
battle
it's a lonely death for the rotifer with
only the kentrophilum to witness it
though I suppose now there is also us
sharing and immortalizing that rotifers
final moments
and if the rotifer had not died in the
body of another organism it may have
ended up like this gastro trick now to
be fair they did find themselves in a
very similar situation they are both
dead but the rotifer was eaten alive
digested from the outside while trapped
in another organism meanwhile this
gastro trick is going through the exact
opposite situation it is being eaten
From the Inside Out by a scavenger
called a paranima now as far as we know
the piranima didn't do anything to kill
the gastro trick it was likely already
dead that we don't know what killed it
but the parenima is both a hunter and a
scavenger sometimes it can be found with
other pyranima as they hunt down prey in
a pack of hungry microbes
at other times the peranima scavenges
they are notorious for being able to
squeeze their way into whatever holes
they find to get into a dead organism
and in this case the gastrotrix
exoskeleton was the right combination of
available open and dead for the
peranimum which found its way in and
decided to begin helping itself to the
buffet of dead tissue around it after
all the gastro trick won't be needing
that tissue anymore so the pyranima
might as well make good use of it
the gastrotrich's body has likely
vanished by now perhaps the piranimal
will have finished it off entirely or
some other scavenger will have joined in
on the fun or perhaps it will have
simply faded like the rotifer inside the
kentrophilum its body eventually Fading
Into the world that encapsulates it
but for this last moment let's remember
the gastro trick in a more beautiful
moment under a fluorescent light blowing
and the Glorious purple autofluorescence
of its remains
[Music]
foreign
if you think that microbes are the only
organisms that eat microbes think again
we humans have a particular fondness for
one specific fungus called saccharomyces
cerevisiae but you probably know it
better as yeast often when we talk about
the invisible role that microbes have
played in human history we're talking
about the destruction wrought by
diseases but as we'll talk about in the
next video the life of saccharomyces
serovicier has intertwined with our own
in ways that are both delicious and
mysterious
foreign
[Music]
or drink a glass of beer you are
participating in what might be depending
on how strict you are about your
definitions one of the longest running
microbiology experiments in human
history
while the earliest scientific studies of
microbes usually go back only a few
centuries when it comes to yeast the
microbe at the core of some of our
favorite foods and drinks well those
past few centuries barely scratch the
surface but before we get to that
history let's start with some of the
basic biology yeast are a fungus though
unlike many in that Kingdom they don't
grow the branching hyphy that
characterize organisms like mushrooms
instead yeast grow primarily through a
process of asexual reproduction called
budding
while there are many yeast species found
among different fungal phyla perhaps the
most well-known is saccharomyces
cerevisii which you might see labeled as
brewers yeast or baker's yeast along
with a few other yeasts these various
strains of s cerevisiai are what we've
come to rely on for our beer wine and
bread and all through the magic of
fermentation yeast like many organisms
rely on different metabolic pathways to
break down sugar and create energy these
processes usually rely on oxygen but to
deal with situations where oxygen may be
less readily available or some of their
key metabolic processes are shut down
yeast turn to alcoholic fermentation
fermentation helps the yeast get the
energy it needs but the particular
chemical path they follow also produces
ethanol and carbon dioxide the yeast
doesn't need these byproducts in fact
too much ethanol could be toxic for them
but what is waste to a yeast is treasure
to us
and that shift in metabolic activity has
been making our bread rise and our
brains woozy for millennia
foreign
studies of pottery jars found in China
found that they may have held some kind
of fermented beverage as far back as 7
000 BCE and archaeological evidence has
turned up for leavened bread from 2000
BCE in Egypt and a thousand BCE in
Northwestern China it's easy to see why
our use of yeast has persisted for
Millennia to quote one group of
scientists it helped us make food and
drinks with a quote enriched sensorial
palette and also a quote euphorient
effect
but the long-standing ubiquity of yeast
also emphasizes how mysterious their
Origins are we don't actually know how
yeast became involved with our cooking
we just know that it was ancient likely
starting with wine and would come to
span continents potentially spreading
through trade the results were food and
drinks produced through a series of
observations about how factories like
temperature time and air might affect
the final product to quote Samuel
Johnson's 18th century dictionary Barm a
type of yeast is quote the ferment put
into drink to make it work and into
bread to lighten and swell it
the time they didn't know what was
actually in yeast or how it worked to
shape those results we just knew it was
a thing that provided something somehow
moreover the earliest glimpses of yeast
under the microscope seemed to support
the idea that yeast was just some sort
of chemical of fermenting agent not a
biological entity of its own when
Anthony Von lavenhoek observed yeast in
the 17th century he thought they were
just bits of globular particles against
the new and incredible bits of life he
was seeing for the first time through
the microscope yeast seemed useful But
ultimately unliving
but over the next few centuries as more
scientists worked to try and understand
how fermentation actually worked they
identified not just the chemical
reactions that shaped the process but
that yeast was an actual living organism
essential to fermentation eventually
Louis Pasteur would put all the pieces
together publishing a paper called the
Memoir of the fermentation of alcohol or
something like that but in French it was
published in 1857 and it established the
interplay between chemistry and biology
that allowed yeast to turn to alcoholic
fermentation to survive it would also
later uncover another form of
fermentation carried out by bacteria
which is called a lactic acid
fermentation
Pasteur's work didn't just change our
understanding of how bread was made it
would go on to inform our understanding
of germ Theory and how the invisible
world of microbes connects to the Grim
realities of disease from this early
history yeast have gone on to become
perhaps one of the most studied
eukaryotic organisms in modern
biological research saccharomyces
cerevisiae in particular has had an
illustrious research career in 1996 its
genome was fully sequenced making it the
first eukaryotic organism to be
genetically mapped out
part of what makes yeast such great
Research Organisms is that they are easy
to grow and manipulate both through
environmental and genetic means which
has allowed us to use them to study
everything from DNA replication to prion
diseases in the same way that cultures
have refined the ways we use yeast in
our food and drinks scientists have
refined the way we use yeast in our lab
experiments they've even developed
genetic engineering techniques that
repurpose yeast to brew the ingredients
for everything from perfumes to
anti-malarial drugs when you consider
just how far we've come with yeast you
might begin to wonder did we domesticate
them after all our early days of yeast
use likely coincided with our early days
of plant and animal domestication so in
the same way that we've come to rely on
domesticated animals for food and labor
maybe yeast are our microbial workhorses
the answer to that question is one that
scientists are actually still studying
in part because the history of yeast is
so large and mysterious and in part
because domestication has a very
specific definition in these
conversations one paper we found
describes it as quote human selection
and breeding of wild species to obtain
cultivated variants that thrive in
man-made environments but behave
sub-optimally in nature that's quite a
number of nuanced requirements to check
off but with this definition in mind
beer yeast seems to show the most
evidence for having been domesticated
which is likely connected to specific
aspects of the Brewing process that have
limited the exposure of the domesticated
yeast to Wild yeast but all yeasts
considered the genetic analysis of beer
yeast strains show that this
domestication is actually relatively
recent as in it only happened a few
centuries ago while it did happen before
we even knew that yeast was a living
thing that we were domesticating it
still came long after we started using
yeast to make beer leaving much of the
organism's history still a mystery
it is often tempting to think that we
have a microbial world and a human world
that intersect only in chemical
reactions and biological connections but
yeast reminds us that microbes are more
than just a scientific reality they are
a cultural one even when we didn't know
they were around yeast have created our
Foods shaped our traditions and both
bonded and divided Us and how we use and
change yeast will only continue to shape
Our Lives their future tied so much to
our own as every bit as Grand and
mysterious as their past has been
foreign
there is but one inevitable way to end
all this with poop because yes even
microbes do it not all that we eat can
be retained in our bodies something must
exit so come for the funny videos of
microbes pooping stay for the extra
lesson on how they do it without a
butthole
[Music]
our food one of life's great Pleasures
whether you're an organism whose body
can create its own food or you make do
with the consumption of other organisms
food sustains and connects life both
large and small but we're not going to
talk about food today we're going to
talk about what happens
after no great meal comes without
consequences even photosynthetic
microbes produce oxygen they don't need
a byproduct that is quite useful to many
other organisms including us and for
organisms that have to digest their food
to extract nutrients well there's all
sorts of stuff left behind when the
process is done in the world of the
micro Cosmos there are not only many
varied tiny organisms there are also
many varied ways to produce even tinier
poop
[Music]
and when we say tinier we mean it if
you're worried about being grossed out
by this video or you really want to make
sure you're not missing anything just
know that some of this pooping will
require you to pay very close attention
some of this will probably look similar
to macroscopic bowel movements and some
will seem less so so let's start with
the more poop-like poop that comes from
some of the multicellular members of the
microcosmos particularly the ones with
digestive systems complete with
specialized regions for digesting food
and releasing solid waste
our dragon-like friend the gastro trick
is doing the old scrunchion poop
probably after having finished a nice
meal made up of bacteria or protozoa the
food that came in through its pharynx
was then sent through the intestine a
straight tube full of digestive cells
after the remains continued their way to
the end of the tube where lies the anus
a microscopic Gateway out of the gastro
trick and into the world
that's all well and good for the more
complex organisms but how does one poop
when one does not have a butthole
well for some single-celled organisms
one becomes the butthole
such is the case for amoebas their
formlessness allows them to easily shift
their shape around to take in food via
phagocytosis the amoeba here happens to
have found a nice meal made of a ciliate
which is now contained in a food vacuole
filling with digestive enzymes those
enzymes will eventually break the
ciliate down allowing the amoeba to
absorb nutrients into its cytoplasm
but then what happens with the remains
well as we see with this amoeba here it
gets released amoebas and other similar
organisms use a process called
exocytosis to send waste back to the
membrane where it is removed from their
body
[Music]
you can see this again here in this
mastic amoeba slowly gliding along the
microscope slide while a round bit seems
to come off up top it almost looks like
it's leaving behind a little piece of
itself which I mean
maybe it is
[Music]
ciliates have a more refined approach to
pooping which is to say they have the
unicellular equivalent of an anus called
a cytoproct
ciliates gather food into an oral Groove
and then consume it in the digestive
vacuoles that travel through the cell
eventually when the vacuole makes its
way to the cytoproct the contents get
out
and there you have ciliate poop
the way organisms poop the way microbes
poop are even more varied and wonderful
than we've been able to show you here
but you might be wondering how you get
from something relatively simple like
this ciliate releasing a small bit of
waste to something more complex like
this tardigrade with its more
compartmentalized approach to defecation
the answer of course is evolution but
it's an answer that leads to many more
unanswered questions even within animals
the evolution of the anus or in some
species the cloaca is not well
understood as discussed in a 2015 review
paper with these spectacular title
getting to the bottom of anal evolution
and while the anus itself is linked to
the evolution of a digestive system not
all metazoans have a designated anus the
Hydra gut has only one opening which
means that the organism's mouth has to
pull digestive double duty and open back
up to release the waste and how that
system fits in with the evolution of
digestion overall is unclear much like
the evolution of sex anuses are a trait
that appears and disappears in
evolutionary lineages reflecting the
fact that they might be useful for some
animals and less so for others
The Duality of the hydra's mouth seems
to be working out great for them after
all but having a digestive system with a
distinct entrance and exit is pretty
handy too
one it's just a little less disgusting
but it also keeps food flowing in One
Direction and that means animals like
the tardigrade and us don't have to wait
to finish digesting to eat more food
that would be annoying we just get to
keep eating all thanks to that
evolutionary mystery that is the anus
in the end though anus or not Everybody
Poops food after all might be one of
life's great Pleasures but all good
things must come to an end
and perhaps with the microcosmos we can
find some pleasure in that as well
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us the names on the
screen right now these are some of our
patreon patrons the people who have
decided to directly support this channel
over at patreon.com journey to micro and
we thank them so much for their
continued support
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes James Weiss check out jam
and germs on Instagram and Tick Tock and
you can also find Journey to the micro
Cosmos on Tick Tock now if you want some
micro microcosmos a couple times a week
and if you want to see more from us here
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]